ur pour endiguer le début de l'épidémie
elles ont été prises dans les aéroports
pour gagner de précieuses semaines qui
nous ont été utiles ensuite pour nous
préparer et préparer nos hôpitaux
préparer notre société une fois
l'épidémie malheureusement installé nous
avons dû du fait de sa croissance
exponentielle mettre en place un
confinement sous l'égide bien évidemment
du président de la république et du
gouvernement pour permettre un coup
d'arrêt massif à la circulation du virus
ce confinement je le rappelle et je ne
le rappellera jamais assez a permis de
prendre en charge tous les malades qui
en avaient besoin
dans les zones les plus touchées paris
en faisant partie cela nous a permis de
faire des évacuations sanitaires mais
également de compter sur les renforts de
nombreux soignants venant de province
qui ont aidé nos hôpitaux
c'est grâce à ce coup d'arrêt de l'epic
que les de l'épidémie que le
gouvernement a pu envisager un
déconfinement les confinements
progressif adapté aux réalités du
terrain et à celui des connaissances
scientifiques et au cours de l'ensemble
de ces périodes et en particulier du
déconfinement il y a eu des adaptations
et je veux dire que tout cela est tout à
fait normal des adaptations allant dans
le sens d'une plus grande souplesse des
activités économiques au furet au fur et
à mesure de la consolidation des
protocoles sanitaires améliorées
petit à petit des restrictions le sur
les mêmes marchés ont été ainsi
supprimées progressivement sur les
centres commerciaux les foires les
salons les événements de voie publique
des adaptations également allant dans le
sens d'un resserrement des contraintes
sanitaires dans le champ des activités
sociales
au vu de la dégradation des indicateurs
de l'été j'ai donc ainsi pris un premier
arrêté obligeant à porter le masque sur
certains espaces de paris et puis dans
un deuxième temps que généralisant sur
l'ensemble de la capitale
à chaque fois à chaque fois
ces décisions ont été prises sur la base
d'indicateurs
l'indicateur sanitaire c'est à dire de
données scientifiques et en collégialité
j'assume parfaitement mes
responsabilités c'est moi qui ai pris
ces mesures est elle le jeu les faits en
raison des pouvoirs qui me sont en la
matière confié dans la gestion de paris
mais je crois important de rappeler que
ces mesures l'ont été car elles ont été
élaborées à partir des constats de
terrain c'est sur le terrain dans les
relations avec la mairie avec les élus
et les échanges avec le monde socio
économique que ces décisions ont pu être
influencé est modifié parfois vous avez
été étonné que des adaptations
surviennent mais c'est le résultat de ce
travail de cette élaboration collégiale
c'est la méthode que le président de la
république a voulu engager appelé de
façon peut-être un peu rapide le couple
maires préfets mais c'est en tout état
de cause le résultat de ce travail de
terrain
ce matin nous franchissons une nouvelle
étape de la même façon que nous l'avait
fait que nous l'avons fait au cours de
ces dix derniers mois
tout cela est normal c'est la preuve que
nous nous adaptons sans cesse à la
réalité de l'épidémie à la réalité du
virus et qu'il faut en permanence
trouver cet équilibre entre la
préservation de la santé de nos
concitoyens et la réalité et les
nécessités de la continuité de la vie
économique et sociale
les mesures que je vais détailler tout à
l'heure après que le préfet de région et
dit un mot un cycle directeur général de
la rs qui nous feront le point sur la
pandémie sont des mesures de freinage
parce que l'épidémie va trop vite il
faut freiner maintenant avant que notre
système de soins ne soit débordé les
chiffres vont vous le démontrez assez
facilement et il faut surtout le faire
en évitant de fracasser notre pays
il ne s'agit pas de stop and go il
s'agit tout simplement d'une réduction
maîtriser des choses pour permettre
ensuite une reprise la plus rapide
possible
les mesures vont être prises pour les
quinze jours qui viennent avec une
réévaluation à l'issue de ces quinze
jours pour voir si nous reconduisons
un certain nombre de mesures si nous les
infléchissant si nous les faisons
évoluer
c'est un processus logique lisible
encore une fois qui sera fait dans la
carte de cette concertation de cette
collégialité de terrain que j'évoquais à
l'instant pour les évaluer je souhaite
que ce processus ait lieu dans la plus
parfaite transparence comme il l'a été
jusqu'à présent nous le devons aux
parisiens et c'est pour cela que les
bonnes ou les mauvaises nouvelles seront
absolument partager et discuter
c'est un processus dans lequel il ne
s'agit pas uniquement de constater la
situation sanitaire de prendre des
mesures d'interdiction mais aussi de
profiter de ce temps là pour élaborer de
nouvelles défense plus solide face au
virus avec des protocoles sanitaires
plus élaboré des évolutions des
protocoles existants sur les avancées
scientifiques qui peuvent se faire je
rappelle à cet égard que contrairement
au début de l'épidémie nous avons
désormais de nouvelles armes
elles sont parfois gosset mais en tout
état de cause nous avons des masques en
grande quantité un nombre de tests
hebdomadaires bien parmi les plus élevés
du monde
le nouveau traitement des plates formes
de trafic de traçage des cas contacts
bref nous améliorons chaque jour nos
performances même si cela n'est
peut-être parfois pas suffisant mais la
perspective est là nous ne ferons pas
simplement un empilement de mesures
administratives toujours plus
contraignante mais un contrat un contrat
avec les parisiens dans lequel toutes
les parties et lève progressivement les
remparts contre le virus président de la
république l'a dit nous devons apprendre
à vivre avec ce virus et cette mission
elle ne repose pas uniquement sur les
épaules des décideurs publics que nous
sommes ici mais elle repose également
sur l'action l'attitude de chacun
c'est très simple porter le masque
réduire ses fréquentations sociales un
cercle plus restreint se laver les mains
ces comportements simples basiques
suffisent déjà assurer une défense
efficace pour soi même et pour les
autres je ne veux pas être plus long
avant de passer la parole au préfet de
région mais simplement le préfet de
police que je suis veut adresser un
grand remerciement au parisien un grand
remerciement aux acteurs économiques
bref à tous ceux qui ont contribué
jusqu'à présent à nous aider dans les
défenses mise en place voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire en introduction un mot
du préfet de région le directeur général
de la rs ensuite je présenterai
l'ensemble des mesures qui seront
destinés décliné dans chacune de leur
secteur
directeur général de la rs pour les
ehpad et par le recteur d'académie pour
ce qui concerne les universités
monsieur le préfet de région monsieur le
préfet de police
madame la maire j'ai un ami dans la
lutte contre la pandémie et sans revenir
sur la phase de mars à août
on a reparlé le préfet de police les
services de l'état en ile de france ont
depuis le début du mois de septembre
tenu des réunions régulières pour
partager l'information sur l'évolution
de la pandémie nous son aggravation et
les mesures prises pour s'adapter à la
situation
les réunions avec les élus notamment
avec ceux de la ville de paris avec mes
acteurs économiques et sociaux au niveau
de la région au niveau des départements
de celle ci cette concertation ces
réunions avec les acteurs économiques
ont reçu pour objet de favoriser le
recours au télétravail l'étalement des
horaires de travail
c'est l'objet du protocole que nous
avons rendu public à la mi septembre
avec le classement de paris et des trois
départements de la petite couronne en
zone écarlate ce besoin de communication
est encore plus impérieux c'est l'objet
de cette conférence de presse où un
directeur général de lairesse le fera
donc le point sur la dernière étape de
la situation et puis comme l'a dit le
préfet de police y reviendra sur les
mesures de police administrative dg
l'air et sur les mesures dans les ehpad
et le recteur sur les mesures dans les
universités sans vouloir être long il
convient bien sûr de se dire que nous
devrons faire le point sur l'impact de
ces mesures est de refaire comme le prêt
ni cela indiquait un point sous quinze
jours de cette situation très simplement
il en va de la compréhension par nos
concitoyens des mesures prises et donc
de leur acceptation de celle ci
le préfet police monsieur le préfet de
la région d'île de france madame la
maire sur le recteur les chiffres
confirment aujourd'hui à paris et en
petite couronne
le dépassement des seuils d'alert qui
justifie le classement de la plaque
parisienne en zone d' alerte maximale
depuis le 28 septembre
quand on reconstitue les chiffres
puisque on a toujours un délai pour
obtenir les chiffres stabiliser le taux
d'incidence est supérieur à deux cent
soixante pour cent mille habitants
a paris il est pour illustrer au dessus
de 500 pour la catégorie des 20 30 ans
catégorie dans laquelle le virus circule
le plus activement en petite couronne ce
taux approche des 200 et poursuit une
tendance à la hausse en particulier dans
les hauts-de-seine et dans le val de
marne pour les plus de 65 ans le taux
d'incidence est aujourd'hui supérieur à
110 pour cent mille habitants à paris et
ce taux a dépassé les 100 dans deux des
trois départements de la petite couronne
enfin et c'est le point le plus
important le taux d'occupation des lits
de réanimation par des patients koffigoh
vide a franchi hier le taux de 36 %
pourquoi une approche paris petite
couronne pour le coup et le préfet de
police l'a indiqué nous avons appris
depuis le début de cette épidémie et
nous avons notamment appris que les
chiffres parisiens sont suivis très
rapidement en quelques jours en quelques
semaines par les chiffres en petite
couronne la densité de population les
échanges journaliers pour le travail ou
pour les loisirs justifie cette unité de
la plaque parisienne et par ailleurs
nous avons une gestion des lits de
réanimation qui est une gestion à
l'échelle régionale
car si nous renvoyons chaque département
à sa capacité en réanimation
nous serions fait dans une sorte d'
accélération des inégalités
donc le premier point c'est que nous
sommes à paris au dessus des trois
critères et ces données sont confirmées
depuis que le ministre de la santé des
solidarités s'est exprimé jeudi nous
avons souhaité vérifier ces données et
nous les avons nous pouvons aujourd'hui
les confirmés deuxième élément sur la
situation sanitaire
nous avons chaque jour en ile-de-france
en moyenne 3500 nouveaux cas confirmés
avec des pics lundi de la semaine
dernière nous avons eu cinq mille 900
cas c'est trois fois et demie plus qu'il
y à un mois et ses nouveaux cas
s'illustre notamment notamment dans des
clusters aujourd'hui deux sans trois
clusters sont actifs en ile de france
c'est à dire qu'il y a trois cas de kobe
de confirmer sur lesquelles l'agencé
régionale de santé mène une enquête pour
limiter le foyer de contamination
ces clusters ils sont pour un peu moins
de 40% dans le milieu scolaire et
universitaire 26% dans le milieu
professionnel et 10% dans des
rassemblements privé ce chiffre ayant
doublé depuis la rentrée
je précise sur ce point que dès que ces
éléments doivent être confirmés
compléter plus exactement par des études
notamment pour identifier des foyers de
contamination que nous n'avons nous
n'arrivons pas forcément à remonter
parce que les gens se sont contaminées
en état avec des personnes qu'ils ne
connaissent pas on reviendra là dessus
notamment sur le risque que représentent
les les bars ou les grands
rassemblements
dernier point l'impact sur le système
hospitalier
cet impact il est aujourd'hui réel et il
est chaque jour un peu plus fort je le
disais 36 % des lits de réanimation de
la région sont occupés par des patients
qu'aux vide
c'est une hausse qui s'accélère de
semaine en semaine
au delà des lits de réanimation dans les
lits d'hospitalisation conventionnel
l'augmentation est forte là aussi on a
aujourd'hui en ile de france
2328 patients avec le co vide qui sont
hospitalisés le nombre des patients en
entrant est un progrès en progression
constante et nous retrouvons les
chiffres que nous connaissions à la fin
du mois de mai aujourd'hui l'âge médian
des patients est de 65 ans et notre
enjeu principal est celui des ressources
humaines nous sommes équipés en
respirateur nous sommes équipés en
médicaments nous sommes équipés en
équipements de protection individuelle
pour les soignants mais évidemment la
tension sur les ressources humaines est
extrêmement forte
c'est que c'est ce qui a conduit un
certain nombre d'établissements à des
programmes et des activités
chirurgicales pour récupérer des
personnels pour venir armés les lits de
réanimation
certains établissements n'ont fait dès
la semaine dernière avec des
déprogrammations qui vont jusqu'à 20%
des activités des programmations qu'est
ce que ça veut dire parce que
quelquefois on a tendance à voir dans ce
mot juste un élément de gestion des
programmations ça venir notamment
reporter une opération une prothèse de
la hanche ou du genou comme c'est fait
dans de nombreux établissements et
quelquefois ces personnes ont déjà vu
ces opérations d programmée au printemps
donc ce sont des situations très
concrètes qui pèse sur la vie des gens
on n'est pas dans une situation
simplement d'adaptation et de faire face
à une légère pression la pression est
forte et nous savons ce qui va se passer
dans les 15 prochains jours
nous savons que nous arriverons autour
de 50 % des lits de réanimation occupés
par des patients qu'aux vide c'est tout
l'enjeu de freiner cette progression
dernier point sur la situation nous
savons le préfet de police l'a redit là
on connaît les outils pour freiner cette
progression la distanciation physiques
et sociales la réduction de ces
interactions sociales et aussi ça a été
rappelé hier et par le premier ministre
et par la ministre de l'emploi et du
travail
le recours au télétravail qui doit être
encouragée dans la région ile-de-france
pour limiter les interactions parce
qu'on sait je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
que le siècle
lieu professionnel est encore lieu fort
de contamination malgré le port du
masque qui pourtant réduit ses
interactions
voilà ce que je pouvais dire sur le
poêle chauffez police merci monsieur le
directeur général j'en viens donc
maintenant aux mesures qui vont être
prises à partir de demain et jusqu'au
lundi 19 octobre inclus l'arrêté qui
sert de support à ces mesures sera
publié immédiatement après 7,7 exposer
cette conférence de presse et une foire
aux questions sera d'ailleurs disponible
sur le site de la préfecture de police
car bien évidemment tout cela pose toute
une série d'interrogations légitimes
auxquelles il faut répondre dans le
détail les mesures qui sont prises
peuvent se résumer en trois axes d'abord
limité les grands rassemblements et
prévenir le brassage de la population
quand ce brassage n'est pas absolument
nécessaire
je reconduire est donc un certain nombre
de mesures d'ores et déjà en vigueur
mais que je rappel il s'agit de
l'interdiction des événements
rassemblant plus de mille personnes en
même temps
cette jauge 2000 ne comprenant pas les
personnels de sécurité
une organisation d'un événement il
s'agit également de l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 10 personnes
sur la voie publique
j'insiste sur cette notion de voie
publique cette règle ne s'applique pas à
l'intérieur des commerces des
entreprises des administrations et
cetera il y a aussi quelques exceptions
à cette règle de limitation
d'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes
les manifestations revendicatives au nom
de la liberté fondamentale de s'exprimer
et de manifester ses opinions pourront
bien évidemment se produire mais
également pourront se produire les
cérémonies funéraires dans les
cimetières
chacun devant pouvoir se recueillir dans
ces moments terribles
les marchés restent aussi ouvert comme
précédemment les rassemblements
professionnels comme les tournages les
visites guidées les chantiers de voie
publique je crois utile de
précisait quelques fois la question est
posée seront bien évidemment maintenu
les distributions alimentaires l'aide
aux plus vulnérables les barnums les
barnums de dépistage de l'aco vides
seront aussi autorisés la limitation à
10 personnes s'appliquant sur les autres
cas je précise également parce que la
question m'a également été de nombreux
soient posés les files d'attentes sur la
voie publique pour une raison x ou y
peu importe son bien sûr possible il
faut avoir une certaine distanciation à
la matière mais elles ne sont pas
considérées comme un rassemblement
ensuite je prends toute une série
d'autres mesures qui comme je le disais
précédemment vise au-delà des
rassemblements à interdire ou limiter
les activités à risque ou limitée des
activités qui rassemble un grand nombre
de personnes au même endroit sans que
ces rassemblements soient absolument
indispensable a compté donc de demain
tous les bars devons être fermes et les
restaurants que l'on définit comme étant
des établissements dont l'activité
principale est la vente de repas c'est
une discussion qui se produit avec les
fédérations professionnelles à ce moment
pourront rester ouverts à leurs horaires
habituels
sous réserve du strict respect d'un
nouveau protocole sanitaire validé par
le haut conseil de santé publique
ce protocole sera détaillé dans la
journée il fera l'objet d'un arrêté
complémentaire de ma part dès lors qu'il
aura été définitivement acté la vente à
emporter d'alcool et la consommation
d'alcool sur la voie publique reste
interdite à compter de 22h ainsi que la
diffusion de musiques amplifiées et cela
sur la voie publique et cela pour éviter
les regroupements sur la voie publique
pour éviter toutes pratiques festives
dans cet espace public
par ailleurs ge interdit explicitement
les soirées étudiantes et tout type de
rassemblement festif ou familiaux dans
les établissements recevant du public
cela ne vise pas bien sûr les lieux
privés mais simplement cer p les
cérémonies de mariage peuvent bien
évidemment avoir lieu dans les mairies
ou dans les lieux de culte mais les
fêtes de mariage dans les rp ne sont pas
autorisés en effet nous avons constaté
de nombreuses contaminations dans ce
type d'événement
les clubs de jeux salle de danse salle
de jeux seront également fermés au
public
ces lieux festifs étant également
propice des brassages de populations
souvent avec consommation d'alcool pour
éviter des regroupements massifs de
populations j'ai également pris la
décision de fermer les foires et salons
parc expositions et les événements se
tenant sous de grandes tentes qu'on
appelle dans le jargon des cts
chapiteaux tentes et structures en
pratique cela veut dire que les congrès
salons professionnels représentation de
cirque sous chapiteau ne pourront se
tenir dans les quinze prochains
prochains jours je rappelle d'ailleurs
que j'aie interdite précédemment des
congrès médicaux de professionnels de
santé qu'il n'aurait pas été raisonnable
de laisser se produire dans la situation
actuelle
s'agissant des activités sportives les
gymnases salles polyvalentes piscine
seront désormais fermés à tout type
d'activité mais en accord et à la
demande du maire de paris
parce que nous entrons dans une période
de vacances scolaires nous avons
souhaité que ces espaces puisse
continuer à accueillir des mineurs
que ce soit dans un cadre scolaire
associatifs ou privés
l'idée étant de permettre aux enfants et
aux jeunes adolescents de pouvoir
continuer à pratiquer un sport ou toute
autre activité dans ses locaux les clubs
de sport club de fils de fitness
resteront fermés également
je leur précise ray dans l'arrêté qui
sera publié dans quelques minutes de
manière à ce que les choses soient
parfaitement claires par rapport à ces
pratiques sportives qui peuvent
représenter également des foyers de
contamination les données sanitaires
ayant évolué en la matière je renouvelle
donc explicitement cette fermeture sur
ces clubs de sport et de fitness
toujours en relation avec la mairie de
paris et pour permettre aux parisiens
qui vivent dans une dans une des villes
les plus denses du monde pour leur
permettre de profiter des expériences
extérieures
le risque de contamination est moindre
j'ai décidé que tous les équipements de
plein air les stades les terrains
d'entraînement physique pourront rester
ouverts à condition de rassembler moins
de 1000 personnes ou 50% de leur
capacité maximale si elle est inférieure
à ce chiffre de 1000 personnes
cette règle qui s'appliquera aussi bien
aux établissements de quartier qu'aux
équipements de haut niveau permettra des
tournois sportifs permettra des tournois
sportifs de se poursuivre dans les mêmes
conditions qu'aujourd'hui je pense en
particulier à roland garros où tous les
matches de football de rugby qui vont
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines pouvoir sous cette
double condition 2000 ou de 50% pouvoir
se réaliser
s'agissant des activités commerciales le
choix a été fait d'encadrer plus
strictement le nombre de personnes
pouvant se croiser dans les grands
centres commerciaux les grands magasins
comme ils ont des caractéristiques et
des tailles très différentes
mettre une jauge fixe n'avait pas de
sens ce délire plafonné en disant c'est
x milliers de personnes n'avaient pas de
sens comme ils ont ces caractéristiques
différentes
l'arrêté prévoit donc que ces
établissements devront accueillir au
maximum un client pour quatre mètres
carrés c'est à dire une stricte
application de la densité prévu dans les
protocoles sanitaires qui ont été en la
matière largement éprouvée je sais pour
en avoir souvent parler avec les
représentants de ses activités
ces règles sont jusqu'à présent assez
globalement respectée et la réduction de
cette surface d'un client par 4 mètres
carrés permettra de garantir avec ce
respect une bonne vitalité économique
absolument nécessaire pour le reste le
directeur général de la rs et le recteur
vous présenteront les mesures dans
quelques secondes spécifique aux ehpad
et aux établissements universitaires
mais je voudrais avant de leur céder à
nouveau la parole précisé que par
construction ce qui n'est pas interdit
est autorisé et je voudrais rappeler ce
qu'il est en la matière les lieux
culturels comme les théâtres les cinémas
les musées seront ouverts en continuant
à appliquer strictement les protocoles
assez sévère qui d'ores et déjà ont été
mis en place
l'activité des entreprises des
administrations devra être encouragée en
matière de télétravail mais continuera à
fonctionner comme par le passé les
services de transport pour lequel le
choix a été fait de continuer à miser
sur une incitation de tout ce qu'ils
peuvent à utiliser d'autres moyens je
suis très attaché madame la maire il ya
un évident ces services de transport
continueront à fonctionner pour
l'application de toutes les mesures
restrictives
j'ai bien évidemment donné instruction à
l'ensemble des services de police placé
sous mon autorité de contrôle et les
établissements je ne parle pas de
verbalisation
elles vont de soi par contre je serais
et nous serons implacables pour ceux qui
veulent en permanence contourner la
règle ils sont très peu nombreux
malheureusement inzaghi il existe et
cela m'arrive encore de fermer un
certain nombre de types d'établissements
mais je suis convaincu que ces règles
s'appliqueront sans ces mesures
restrictives voilà ce que je voulais
préciser monsieur le directeur général
de la rs pour ce qui concerne les ehpad
merci 115 et pat de la région sur les
700 qui existent en ile de france
connaissent un épisode active de
présence du co vide avec au moins une
personne malade
au vu de la situation épidémique et de
sa reprise depuis le début du mois de
septembre l'agencé régionale de santé
avait formulé des recommandations aux
directeurs d'établissements aujourd'hui
ces mesures doivent être systématisé et
généralisée il s'agit comme le préfet de
police vers de l'exposer dans un champ
plus large à la fois de garantir la
protection sanitaire des personnels et
des résidents personne ne nous
pardonnerait de ne pas être au rendez
vous sur ce point là tout en préservant
au maximum le lien social avec les
familles les proches pour éviter
l'isolément mais aussi en limitant les
cas de confinement en chambre des
situations exceptionnelles
là aussi il faut le dire nous avons
appris de la première vague de
l'épidémie et nous essayons de
développer une approche plus graduées de
ce fait les visites seront autorisés
mais uniquement sur rendez vous avec
deux personnes maximum
si possible dans un espace dédié comme
le font aujourd'hui beaucoup d pad
justement pour garantir l'effectivité de
cette possibilité de visite
il est demandé aux établissements de
garantir cette possibilité de
rendez-vous y compris le week-end y
compris hors des horaires de journée
pour que les personnes qui travaillent
puissent aller voir leur famille par
contre j'ai demandé au directeur de
suspendre les visites en cas de non
respect des mesures barrières par les
visiteurs c'est aujourd'hui
là aussi une réalité qui n'est pas la
plus fréquente qui existe est là dessus
l'exemplarité doit être respectée nous
devrons suspendre les sorties
collectives et inciter à limiter les
sorties individuelles et à limiter aussi
les sorties vers la famille je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure je les ai évoqué ce
chiffre de plus de 500 l'incidence chez
les 20 30 ans c'est courir un risque
mais là encore il ne s'agit pas de
mesures couplées et les médecins
notamment les médecins coordonnateurs
des pâtes doivent être à même de juger
pour calibrer le plus justement possible
pour qu'on ne bascule pas dans cet
isolement qui lui aussi tu j'ai demandé
aux établissements de fermer les
accueils de jour qui n'ont pas d'entrée
séparées avec les ehpad pour que les
flux ne se croisent pas tout en
proposant des solutions de répit aux
personnes et à leurs aidants en
s'organisant différemment là aussi
derrière cette affirmation général et
vous le savez pour ceux qui fréquentent
ces établissements n'est pas ne
ressemble pas à un autre et il ya
toujours cette question de comment on
s'organise concrètement dans les lieux
mais globalement nous devons préserver
l'accès aux aidants dont c'est la
journée demain tout en vérifiant que ça
mais pas un risque sanitaire
nous engagerons le dépistage préventif
de tous les professionnels en se tenant
le plus possible à une périodicité de 14
jours nous lançons à partir
d'aujourd'hui une série de tests hantise
et nick dans dix ehpad de chaque
département de la région pour vérifier
l'efficacité de cette solution
ce qui fait 80 et pad en ile-de-france
qui vont tester ce protocole ça ce sont
les critères généraux
évidemment dès qu'un cas survient
évidemment à fortiori si c'est plus d'un
cas nous devrons mettre en place des
mesures plus restrictives
le ce temps que la situation soit
maîtrisée et un temps strictement
proportionnées éventuellement avec des
suspensions temporaires de visite
évidemment avec des dépistages pcr de
tous les agents et résidant avec
l'activé l'activation d'une unité
qu'ovide dédiée aux malades
c'est très important pour éviter là
encore le confinement chambre et
permettre aux personnes même si dans une
unité dédiée co vide de pouvoir
continuer à avoir une sociabilité et
toujours en cas de situation
on pourrait aller à la fermeture des
accueils de jour rattaché à l'ehpad
encore une fois ces cas là sont gérés
par les établissements en lien avec
l'agencé régionale de santé pour mettre
en place le protocole qui va être le
plus près de la situation données avec
un protocole qui comme pour les mesures
générales et évaluer et qui peut être
levée dès lors que nous jugeons la
situation maîtrisée et le mot d'ordre
pour nous c'est qu'aucune de ces
situations ne doit conduire un isolement
à huit clos dans les ehpad
nous accompagnons tous les jours les
établissements de la région pour décider
et fixer avec eux les mesures de gestion
merci
merci monsieur le préfet de police
monsieur le préfet de région madame la
maire monsieur le directeur général je
voudrais tout d'abord remercier
l'ensemble des présidentes et présidents
d'université directrices et directeurs
d'établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et toute la communauté
universitaire en effet face à une
situation inédite
tous se sont mobilisés pour assurer la
rentrée et chacun a su s'adapter
les chiffres témoignent d'ailleurs de
cette mobilisation
si l'on regarde les chiffres cumulés
depuis le début de septembre en ile de
france parmi les étudiants nous avons 7
196 cas confirmés et parmi les
personnels 144 cas et je vous rappelle
que pour toute l'ile-de-france nous
parlons de 700 5000 étudiants et de près
de 52000 personnel mais surtout est ce
qui est à noter c'est que les chiffres
sont en baisse après une série de
clusters qui ont frappé les esprits
la majorité des cas de contamination a
d'ailleurs eu lieu dans la sphère privée
et avant la rentrée
je pense à polytechnique qui a été
obligé de mettre tous ces étudiants
distant ciel et à sciences po qui a fait
de même pour une part importante de ses
étudiants vendredi 1er octobre
nous déconseillons 60 cas positifs 55
étudiants et 5 personnels confirmé pour
toute l'île de france
cela montre une baisse significatif et
une efficacité des organisations qui ont
été mises en place la ministre nous a
assigné un objectif qui est d'assurer
une rentrée universitaire entre
guillemets la plus normale possible
cette rentrée nous l'avons donc
anticiper en lien étroit avec le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et de l'innovation
cela signifiait que pendant l'été il a
eu un dialogue constant entre le
ministère le rectorat les autorités
sanitaires et les établissements le
ministère a envoyé plusieurs circulaires
la dernière date du 7 septembre elle un
produit vous le savez le port
obligatoire du masque partout et elles
présentent à cadre d'organisation des
enseignements en plusieurs niveaux
possible que ce soit un présentiel
jusqu'ici avec une
géant sanitaires renforcés jusqu'à une
activité qui peut être organisée
uniquement en mode à distance les
établissements du supérieur ont donc
anticipé la situation sanitaire dans
laquelle nous nous retrouvons dès la
rentrée il ya eu des aménagements
fonction des publics des lieux des
surfaces de nombreux établissements ont
déjà adopté leur organisation avec une
part de cours à distance et plusieurs
universités ont systématisé la réduction
de leur capacité d'accueil à 50%
cependant et je tiens à le rappeler et à
le souligner une part de présence en
cours est indispensable pour éviter que
nos étudiants ne décroche n'oublions pas
que les étudiants comme les néo
bacheliers ne se sont pas rendus en
cours pendant près de six mois et pour
s'adapter aux méthodes de l'enseignement
supérieur il faut une part de cours à
distance à partir de demain donc dans
tous les lieux
celle de cours en amphithéâtre
réfectoire la capacité d'accueil sera
limité à 50% pour prendre en compte la
situation sanitaire parisienne chacun
s'y est préparé et le comprend pour
conclure je dirais que le rectorat suit
quotidiennement l'évolution sanitaire et
la déclinaison concrète des mesures à
mettre en oeuvre la majorité des
établissements je le répète ont déjà
adopté des formats hybrides les deux
jauges de 50%
mais l'enjeu principal pour la
communauté universitaire s'est adapté
son organisation pédagogique pour
répondre à l'urgence sanitaire bien sûr
mais aussi permettre aux étudiants de
garder un contact réel avec leurs
enseignants pour éviter un décrochage
massif qui toucherait d'abord les
étudiants les plus fragiles socialement
et psychologiquement
comme vous le voyez nous sommes
collectivement préparer au scénario qui
se mure place demain je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le préfet de
police monsieur le préfet de région
monsieur le directeur général de la rs
et monsieur le recteur nous avons tous
conscience que nous entrons dans une
phase nouvelle parce que évidemment ce
virus est là durablement percute nos
vies et que nous devons et c'est le sens
de cette réunion est de cette conférence
commune travailler tous ensemble d'abord
pour protéger les plus fragiles
cela a été dit en mettant en place tous
les dispositifs je pense bien sûr aux
ehpad mais aussi à toutes les personnes
âgées à domicile à toutes les personnes
en situation de handicap et aussi à
toutes les personnes nous le savons qui
parce que en situation de précarité en
situation d'isolement sont aussi parmi
les plus vulnérables donc protégé et ça
nous devons le faire ensemble avec des
mesures qui bien sûr pour un certain
nombre sont des mesures sanitaires sont
la base de ces mesures
elles ont été exprimées par la rs il ya
des mesures de police de police
administrative pour permettre cette
protection
et puis il y a aussi des mesures
d'accompagnement social que la ville
évidemment dans sa double qualité de
ville et de département a d'ores et déjà
engagé d'ailleurs depuis la phase de
confinement
et puis il ya un deuxième aspect que
nous devons avoir absolument à l'esprit
en permanence parce que cette situation
et durable c'est le fait que la vie
puisse continuer à se déployer certes
pas tout à fait comme avant mais que la
vie démocratique la vie économique la
vie culturelle la vie sociale puisse
bien sûr avoir aussi ces espaces son
rythme qui sont absolument
indispensables
on le sait la crise sanitaire
à des conséquences extrêmement dur
dramatique pour beaucoup de familles
dramatiques sur l'activité économique de
notre pays et de notre capitale
particulièrement touchée puisque nous
sommes une ville qui est sur le plan
économique très dépendante de ses
échanges internationaux à partir du
moment où une partie de ces échanges
internationaux et le tourisme en
particulier où le tourisme d'affaires ne
sont plus autorisés ou ne sont plus
aussi possible qu auparavant
eh bien nous avons une situation
économique très dégradé donc vivre avec
et protéger ses seins je crois
l'objectif que nous devons avoir très
clairement je pense et je les exprime et
et je remercie les autorités de l'état
et notamment le premier ministre d'avoir
engagé ce travail très partenariale il
nous faut être méthodique et dans les
quinze jours qui viennent à partir des
décisions qui ont été prises par l'état
d'accompagner ces mesures pour pouvoir
dans quinze jours est dans une situation
qui soit meilleur du point de vue de la
situation épidémiologique
ça veut dire que la ville évidemment
accompagnera et si un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont des mesures finalement
permettant l'ouverture des restaurants
dans des conditions très particulières
c'est vrai l'ouverture des espaces
publics je pense bien sûr
au stade au jardin etc et un certain
nombre d'activités pour que cela puisse
être possible
la ville m 1 absolument tous ses
services en situation d'accompagner
l'état pour que cette vie puisse être
rendue possible ça veut dire mobiliser
aussi ce qui sera notre futur police
municipale donc nos équipes de
prévention et de sécurité aux côtés des
parisiens mais mobilisé aussi
l'ensemble de nos équipes chargées
notamment de l'accompagnement social des
publics et notamment des plus fragiles
il va nous falloir vivre de cette façon
là travailler de façon méthodique ça
veut dire que ce rendez vous nous
l'aurons à nouveau dans quinze jours ça
veut dire de la transparence totale sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie ça veut dire
aussi affiner la connaissance de cette
épidémie et des publics les plus
fragiles
affiné aussi la façon dont les clusters
identifiés jouent un rôle plus ou moins
important dans la diffusion de
l'épidémie du virus donc ça veut dire
pour nous aussi côté vil est cotée et à
un travail quotidien permanent pour
garantir à nos concitoyens je parle ici
bien sûr aux parisiens et je sais que
ces mesures s'appliquent aussi cela a
été dit à la petite couronne garantir la
transparence garantir l'accompagnement
et garantir en permanence aussi des
modalités qui nous permette d'avoir
cette vie économique sociale culturelle
démocratique dont nous avons et
sportives dont nous avons absolument
besoin donc la ville sera aux côtés de
l'état et accompagnera ces mesures nous
serons extrêmement vigilants
effectivement à ce qu'il y ait toute
cette transparence et que dans quinze
jours même s'il y aura des rendez vous
entre nous quotidien dans 15 jours nous
puissions sortir de cette situation et
nous inscrire dans la durée
je crois que c'est l'élément fondamental
pour moi nous inscrire dans la durée
pour pouvoir nous adapter et on ne
s'adaptera que avec ces éléments là je
voudrais dire deux mots
en conclusion d'abord un mot pour les
acteurs économiques
là aussi évidemment compte tenu des
nouvelles mesures qui pour certaines
vont bien sûr encore les impacts et nous
serons aussi très vigilants et aux côtés
de l'état pour qu'il y ait toutes les
mesures d'accompagnement qui permettent
du mieux possible d'éviter des
fermetures des licenciements et une
situation économique qui est déjà
extrêmement dégradée je le dis ici on
sera à leurs côtés et avec mes équipes
nous les réuniront aussi pour être
vraiment à leurs côtés travailler
ensemble un mot sur l'hôpital et sur la
situation que l'on observe aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux
s'il nous faut être aussi méthodique et
engagés et déterminés à l'instant où
nous parlons d'une même voix ici à la
préfecture de police de paris
c'est parce qu'il faut effectivement
faire en sorte que la pression sur les
hôpitaux soient moindres et nous savons
que il faut absolument éviter d'abord la
surcharge et deuxièmement évidemment les
déprogrammations des des opérations qui
ne sont pas liées au co guide pour cela
bien sûr j'apporte tout mon soutien et
vraiment mon soutien et mon affection
aux personnels des hôpitaux publics
je leur dis que nous sommes vraiment à
leurs côtés il y aura aussi un conseil
de surveillance de l'ap-hp à la fin de
cette semaine nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler de leur situation et de faire
en sorte que toutes les solutions
permettant d'améliorer
leur situation et leurs conditions de
travail dans cette phase complexes
soient trouvées en tous les cas je m'y
engage
là aussi très clairement avec beaucoup
de détermination et je pense que sur cet
aspect des choses
il nous faut et ce sera un des rôles que
nous assumons au niveau de la ville que
nous travaillons de façon extrêmement
ouverte avec l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé
je pense bien sûr aux médecins libéraux
infirmiers et infirmières libérales aux
pharmaciens que nous deux et bien sûr à
tous nos centres de santé les maisons
que nous avons aussi médicalisé qui
permettent d'accueillir les parisiennes
et les parisiens
nous devons travailler en réseau à
l'échelle de territoire le plus fin
possible et c'est ce que nous allons
aussi poursuivre mais de façon encore
plus méthodique
pendant les 15 jours qui viennent pour
pouvoir revenir dans quinze jours avec
je l'espère des bonnes nouvelles sur le
front de l'épidémie sur vous remercie
figaro live il est presque midi et quart
bienvenue en ce lundi 5 octobre 2020 a
donc vécu ensemble bien ce point presse
des autorités à paris l' agence
régionale de santé la mère évidemment
anne hidalgo le préfet de police
les nouvelles mesures pour paris et la
petite couronne après le passage en zone
d' alerte maximale si vous venez de nous
rejoindre bienvenu on est ensemble sur
tweets sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr on va
revenir sur les annonces et les
décrypter avec nous en plateau tristan
vais bonjour tristan bonjour chef
adjoint du service santé médecine au
figaro depuis dans un instant on sera
aussi avec claire conneries tu quand on
vite pardon du figaro étudiant pour
débriefer cette fois les annonces du
recteur d'académie à tout ce qui
concerne le milieu universitaire bonjour
je salue déjà toutes celles et ceux qui
sont avec nous vit en terre tellement de
trader qui est avec nous sur twitter the
phoenix bonjour et bienvenu merci d'être
avec nous bonjour à david qui est sur
lefigaro.fr ou encore à toutes celles et
ceux qui nous suivent sur you tube man
ou geoffrey ou encore weasley qu un
petit débrief à chaud comme ça triste
ont raison les les informations qu'on
vient d'avoir on les avait plus ou moins
déjà ce matin finalement oui pas de pad
énorme surprise le préfet l'allemand a
fait a égrainé un peu les mesures qui
devaient être prises
ce qu'on attendait c'était savoir un peu
quel était le protocole sanitaire
réservé pour les pour les restaurants
qui permettent leur ouverture qui paraît
assez étonnante dans ce contexte mais
depuis début de cette crise les mesures
sont pas toujours très claires on est
quelques chiffres de l' ars oi situation
épidémiologique un peu mis à jour
voilà qui qui monte qui laisse
comprendre que la situation n'est pas
bonne mais bon encore une fois la
conférence de presse a pas montré de ils
n'ont pas montré de courbe ils n'ont pas
montré sa voix là je les ai pas trouvés
malheureusement très pédagogique
à ce niveau là la situation n'est pas
bonne en ile de france et il faut
prendre des mesures
donc voilà la fermeture des bars est la
principale mesure pour le reste je
déplore qu'ils aient pas eu d'appel à
respecter dans la sphère privée
les gestes barrière de réduire les
réunions de famille
ce genre de choses toujours pas un mot
là-dessus alors c'est quand même
fondamental quant au milieu scolaire on
nous a dit qu'il y avait 40% des
clusters en ile-de-france qui était lié
aux milieux scolaires et encore une fois
on n'a pas eu de spécialement
d'éclaircissements sur les mesures qui
étaient apportées pour lutter contre ça
notamment sur le port du masque chez les
élèves voilà je suis un peu étonnée
qu'on ait eu cette conférence de presse
qu'au final on n'a pas appris grand
chose je sais pas cet électrochoc dans
les
les franciliens ont peut-être besoin
voilà pour une saison épidémique on y
reviendra peut-être qu'ils qui continue
à se dégrader malheureusement pas
refermée pour 15 jours jusqu'au lundi 19
octobre inclus les restaurants qui
peuvent rester ouverts aux horaires
habituels on avait parlé d'une fermeture
à 22 heures mais finalement il pourra y
avoir deux services le soir par exemple
sous respect du nouveau protocole
sanitaire qui va être validée par le
haut conseil de la santé publique et ce
sera dans la journée on parle de venir
poser les additions à table de m à
mettre 50 entre entre chaque table de
prendre les coordonnées des clients
est-ce que selon vous tristan si ces
mesures se confiant ça suffirait à
endiguer l'épidémie
je je je pense pas que ça suffira
spécialement endiguer l'épidémie mais je
ne pense pas non plus que la fermeture
des restaurants
aurait été fondamental
non plus on sait qu il peut y avoir des
classes dans les restaurants mais encore
une fois quand on voit les chiffres
c'est quand même voilà près de la moitié
en milieu scolaire donc même si c'est
pas des gens qui font des formes graves
ils peuvent ensuite propagé dans la
sphère privée
c'est à dire à leurs parents dans ce
titre ce pas trop grands parents ça
c'est un vrai problème sans qu'on parle
forcément de kloster mais du coup voilà
il ya 25% en milieu professionnel donc
là encore voilà l'appel au télétravail
je trouve a été très clairement formulés
ou passé fortement formulée voilà 10 %
va se faire priver ben voilà pas de
réponse non plus à ça donc voilà les
restaurants je pense que c'est un peu
anecdotique c'est juste que ça va ça va
entretenir une chance un espèce de
double traitement entre les bars les
restaurants voilà après la fermeture des
bars
je pense que c'est une quelque chose qui
est qui utile pour faire passer un
message mais c'est un métier public mais
quelques instants leur d'abord sur les
mesures a rappelé les mesures celles qui
concernent les ehpad visites sur
rendez-vous deux personnes maximum et si
possible dans un espace dédié il y aura
un dépistage préventif des personnels un
dépistage qui sera renouvelée
semble-t-il tous les quinze jours en
tout cas c'est l'objectif qui a été
donnée par le directeur régional
le directeur régional général de
l'agencé régionale de santé
et puis le recours au télétravail qui
doit être encouragée en ile de france
on a même eu une communication en ce
matin du gouvernement qui est disponible
sur lefigaro.fr appelant à justement à
renforcer le télétravail les chiffres on
en parlait il ya quelques instants un
tristan v on a eu l'explication du taux
d'incidence est ce qu on peut rappeler à
toutes celles et ceux qui n'auraient pas
forcément comment ça marche se court ce
qu'on veut définir derrière ces termes
est ce que c'est que le taux d'incidence
qui inquiète en ce moment alors le taux
d'incidence c c'est donc le nombre de
personnes positives
un test sur les sept derniers jours
rapporté à cent mille personnes
donc là en l'occurrence il est
actuellement à paris au delà de 260
il ya 260 personnes positives
ces sept derniers jours pour cent mille
habitants donc il suffit de multiplier
après pour paris typiquement je crois
que c'est 12 4 millions de personnes de
d'habitants intra muros
il faut multiplier par 20 ou 40 en
fonction pour voir le nombre de nouveaux
cas ce taux d'incidence donc çà çà çà
quantifie en fait le nombre de personnes
nouvellement malades sur une semaine
ensuite il ya un taux d'incidence pour
les plus de 65 ans donc là c'est pareil
c'est le nombre de personnes positives
par rapport à 100000 habitants de plus
de 65 ans ils voient le taux aussi est
très supérieur à 100 à paris ce qui
n'est pas encore le cas
forcément en petite couronne mais voilà
comme l'a expliqué pour le coup le le
préfet assez logiquement entre paris à
vis de couronnes voilà tous les
parisiens le savent il n'y a pas de
différence voilà tous les gens qui
habitent en banlieue travail dans paris
les gens qui habitent dans paris peuvent
être travaillés en banlieue les échanges
sont extrêmement importants entre les
entre ces deux zones voilà c'est le
grand paris qui de fait existe déjà dans
sa logique
et puis alors on va essayer de vous
noyer sous les chiffres en tout cas
parlons aussi des lits de réanimation
qui sont occupés à plus d'un tiers 1 36%
en ce moment du côté de la psp à
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
et un lit sur deux sera bientôt occuper
mais on a l'impression que l'objectif
c'est
d'essayer de ne pas dépasser ce chiffre
de 50% en tout cas c'est le chiffre le
chiffre c'est 60% dans pour déclarer
l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est le
critère qui a été définie les dix jours
par le gouvernement
donc voilà l'obligé à ne pas dépasser ce
seuil sachant qu'à une inertie une
inertie
là on constate une stabilisation du
nombre d'entrées en réanimation mais qui
est lié aussi à un premier plateau
épidémique qu'on a pu rencontrer il ya
deux semaines les deux sont probablement
corrélés or le taux d'incidence lui
repart à la hausse depuis quelques jours
les chiffres qui sont tombés ce week-end
ont montré un redémarrage donc le
plateau ne s'est pas confirmée il ya pas
eu de redescendre comme ça on a pu le
constater à bordeaux ou dans les bouches
du rhône
donc on peut craindre que ce chiffre des
réanimations repartent lui aussi à la
hausse
voyez les projections il faut prendre
avec beaucoup de prudence que le but des
projections cessé d'alerter sur une
situation d'engorgement des réanimations
mais le but c'est aussi de faire en
sorte que les mesures de prendre des
mesures pour éviter et donc pour que
c'est ces modélisations justement soit
démentie actuellement elle montre que
dans une grande partie de la france on
on dépasserait les 60 % à la mi novembre
là tout le but justement des mesures qui
sont prises aujourd'hui c'est de faire
en sorte de faire mentir ces
modélisations donc voilà on va voir quel
sera l'effet des mesures prises
aujourd'hui à paris on est une question
de wils coq est avec nous sur youtube
qui se demande simplement si on va être
confiné on peut aller plus loin et
mettre conditionnel est ce qu'on
pourrait être confiné en tout cas à
paris dans la petite couronne et comment
ça pourrait s'organiser alors tout
dépend ce qu'on entend par reconfirmer
jeu
je ne pense pas qu'on vivra un
confinement ses drastiques que ce qu'on
a vécu tout simplement parce que les
implications économiques et sociétales
sont trop nombreuses trop difficile
c'est dur pour peut-être les
personnalistes ali mais le jeu n'en vaut
pas forcément la chandelle je pense pas
qu'on qu'on retournera là dedans en
revanche voir un durcissement beaucoup
plus drastiques que celui qu'on voit
aujourd'hui ça me semble possible
la viande bien quelques autres annonces
arbres plutôt des confirmations
interdiction des événements de plus de
1000 personnes interdiction d'un
rassemblement de plus de 10 personnes
sur la voie publique les cérémonies
funéraires dans les cimetières qui
peuvent être maintenus les marchés qui
restent ouverts il ya quand même à se
contenter de peu mais il ya quand même
des bonnes nouvelles aussi les
rassemblements professionnels comme les
tournages les rassemblant sur les
chantiers aussi sont maintenus il ya eu
des choses quand même assez étonnant
dans cette conférence de presse les
files d'attentes sont possibles ce qui
n'est pas interdit est autorisé a dit le
préfet de police
on peut on peut presque avoir
l'impression que c'est du second degré
alors que la situation sanitaire appelle
à l'urgence dans l'action l'urgence je
pense qu'il faut être relatifs à la
situation est préoccupante mais la
vitesse de propagation du virus n'est
pas la même qu'en avril qu'en avril
dernier en mars avril dernier et le coup
ça nous laisse un peu plus de temps donc
les mesures on sent pas très différente
de celle qu'ils avaient avant je pense
qu'on pouvait attendre c'était un
durcissement dans le ton dans le
l'appel à l'autodiscipline voilà je le
vends cette conférence de presse que son
format même semble peu propice à
convaincre les personnes et pour ce qui
est des mesures en elle-même avoir la
fermeture des bars il n'y a pas grand
chose de très de très nouveau
en même temps si on veut laisser les
l'activité économique culturelle et
sociale se poursuivre c'était difficile
de prendre des mesures beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus forte quand c'est surtout
à une prise de conscience collective
dont on voit quelle qu'elles ne s'opère
pas les gens pensent que c'est pas
vraiment leurs problèmes qu'eux ils ont
peu de chance de tomber malade juillet
un chiffre qui j'ai trouvé assez
frappant et sur lequel ils n'ont pas
insisté du tout mais ils ont dit voilà
l'âge médian est de 65 ans je pense que
personne pour les hospitalisations je
pense que personne n'aura relevé ça mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire l'âge médian
et 65 ans ça veut dire que la moitié des
personnes qui sont hospitalisées
aujourd'hui pour le coc vide plus de 65
ans et ça veut aussi dire que la moitié
des personnes qui sont hospitalisées
pour le coc vie d'aujourd'hui ont moins
de 65 ans donc ça concerne tout le monde
c'est pas simplement la mortalité
concerne certes les personnes plus âgées
principalement mais pas uniquement
encore une fois mais pour ce qui des
passages en ré a quand même beaucoup de
gens jeunes qui vont réanimation et qui
s'en sortent
fort heureusement ce qui est à craindre
c'est qu'on n'accuse plus accueillir ces
gens ils sont plus accueillir ces gens
auraient à il est moins évident qu'il
s'en sorte et c'est ça le la crise du
coc vie d'aujourd'hui c'est une crise de
des capacités hospitalières et c'est pas
simplement pour que les herbes et les
médecins c'est derrière ce qui a été
encore une fois je ne comprends pas
qu'on qu'on n'insiste pas plus là dessus
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya des gens qui
vont réanimation aujourd'hui qui sont
sauvées et la crainte c'est que si
l'épidémie se poursuit à ce rythme là
l'erea soient débordés et des gens qui
auraient pu être sauvées ne puisse plus
l'être c'est ça le c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est pas de vous empêcher d'avoir une
grippe si vous voulez quelqu'un et 30
ans et qu'ils fassent
un kobe de modérer plus ou moins modérée
chez lui en soi c'est évidemment que
c'est que ça c'est pas grave la crainte
c'est que cette personne la haye
contaminé quelqu'un ou soit à risque et
finissant réa et que à terme
voilà les capacités en rien son très
limité donc c'est normal ne pas
connaître forcément 12 personnes qui ont
fini arias forte heureusement il en faut
pas forcément beaucoup pour dépasser
dépasser les capacités hospitalières
voilà on est de france au delà de
quelques milliers c'est terminé a
justement en france à l'échelle
nationale pour élargir un peu pour
élargir à l'échelle du territoire
est ce son elle monte à combien de lits
ses capacités en réanimation
de mémoire c'est c7000 ou 5000 moi je
suis je ne suis pas très je m'appelle
pêcher sans plus ils ont beaucoup changé
quand armes délit on peut augmenter les
capacités s'est tenue trois mille cinq
cents voilà c'est pas c'est pas énorme
quoi est donc aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de gens qui s'en sortent
après un passage en réanimation parce
qu'ils sont bien soignés etc il faut
qu'on continue et ce que les gens aussi
ont du mal peut être à comprendre c'est
que 35% aujourd'hui en ile-de-france qui
sont en réanimation c'est à dire que
dans les lits de réanimation une
personne sur trois a une même maladie
mais ça ça n'arrive jamais demandé aux
réanimateurs c'est quelque chose qu'ils
ont jamais vécu de leur vie ils ont
jamais 35% de leurs patients qui ont la
grippe dans les services de réanimation
ccc ça je pense qu'on a du mal à
percevoir c'est comme une maladie qui
tue peu fort heureusement le sa létalité
on va dire relativement faibles beaucoup
moins importante que pour le strass ou
le maire ce mais ça envoie quand même
des gens en réanimation un certain
nombre est suffisamment pour pour
dépasser avec une capacité c'est ça tout
l'enjeu donc les mesures qui nous sont
demandées aujourd'hui c'est de faire en
sorte d'essayer de faire en sorte que
collectivement le virus circule un peu
moins pour qu'un peu moins de gens se
retrouvent en réanimation et qu'on se
retrouve dans une situation où les
médecins devraient on a frôlé la
catastrophe
en mars dernier il a fallu qu'on fini
parce que l'épidémie aller beaucoup plus
vite et c'est moi qui l'aï lavé les
points de mesures fortes
aujourd'hui on a des chances que le
virus circule moins vite on a un peu
plus de on a un peu plus de temps pour
anticiper mais il faut quand même une
prise de conscience collective que en
faisant un petit effort chacun de notre
côté en limitant les grands dîners chez
soi les fêtes
voilà on participe à limiter la
propagation du virus
justement ces limitations et concerne
beaucoup le monde étudiant aujourd'hui
on va se tourner vers claire conduite
qu'on remercie d'ailleurs patienté qui
est avec nous à distance un journaliste
au figaro étudiant rebonjour clair bon
finalement on a entendu le recteur
d'académie de paris mais
on avait déjà les informations en tout
cas les il va y avoir une diminution
drastique du nombre d'étudiants
accueillis sur les campus et sur les
sites des universités de paris et de la
petite couronne
oui c'est quelque chose qui a été
annoncé hier par matignon donc là encore
ce n'est pas surprenant
à noter quand même que la capacité
d'accueil limitée à 50 % concerne les
amphis les salles mais aussi les
restaurants universitaires et les
bibliothèques universitaires
donc c'est important de le souligner
parce qu'en fait la queue les
contaminations ne concerne pas seulement
les étudiants qui sont statiques en
couvre dans des amphis mais surtout les
étudiants qui vont d'une pièce à l'autre
de la bibliothèque au restaurant
universitaire et qui crée un flux de
passage constant et et parfois ça donne
des images assez impressionnant de
couloir très encombré dans fissures
bondé de d'élèves qui suivent des cours
du couloir entassés les uns sur les
autres et donc c'était important aussi
de 2,2 peut-être limiter cette capacité
d'accueil à noter aussi que les
établissements et les écoles les
universités n'ont pas attendu que cette
mesure soit soit demandé il ya beaucoup
d'établissements et puis cela a été dit
pendant la conférence de presse d
beaucoup d'établissements qui ont mis en
place un enseignement à distance qui ont
essayé de diviser leur que la leur
classe la moitié en dix ans ciel l'autre
en présentiel et 2 et de créer une forme
d'alternance semaine à pour les premiers
semaine b pour les seconds donc tout
cela dans une logique de s'adapter au
mieux à la crise sanitaire
alors justement en parlant
d'enseignement à distance circulaire le
recteur de l'académie de paris
employez le cette expression il faut
maintenir le contact entre les étudiants
et les enseignants
par questions sur le sujet ce que dans
les retours que vous avez du côté du
figaro étudiant bas cet enseignement à
distance
même s'il est partiel ou temporaire est
ce que depuis cette rentrée ça
fonctionne bien est ce que les retours
sont bons ça dépend tout d'abord les les
choses qui ont été mises en place pour
favoriser le distant ciel tout cela
varie d'un établissement à l'autre c'est
à dire qu'il y en a il y en a qui
étaient extrêmement préparer au mieux
que d'autres
pour diverses raisons donc déjà là il ya
une différence à noter entre telle
université qui a réussi à mettre en
place un enseignement hybride et une
autre université qui était un petit peu
plus à la traîne dans la phase
d'adaptation nécessaire qui devait y
avoir
depuis depuis la rentrée mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que en fait le présentiel
salle eu beaucoup de présidents
d'université le répète le présentiel est
une priorité pour quoi bah pour plus
pour des raisons pédagogiques parce que
on ad on a des déjà on a des étudiants à
la fac qui n'ont pas suivi de cours de
façon normale en présentiel depuis
plusieurs mois et au delà de ça il ya
des étudiants en licence 1 donc en
première année d'études qui n'ont même
pas suivi de cours au lycée depuis six
mois donc tout ça ça favorise impossible
décrochage des plus jeunes
mais même un décrochage général et c'est
pour ça que le contact est important à
maintenir évidemment dans la mesure du
respect de des gestes barrières mais il
est important en tout cas pour les
présidents des universités mais aussi
pour les étudiants
il y en a beaucoup qui se plaignent du
fait que les amphis soit bondé mais il y
en a tout autant qu'ils sont contents
aussi de retrouver une vie de campus de
retrouver un lien entre le pot avec le
professeur et et c'est pour ça que
c'était important de maintenir ce lien
en présentiel
oui en plus on peut faire le lien avec
un autre sujet qui est l'orientation
post-bac parcours super on parle souvent
de filière sous tension
et l'île de france les académies d'île
de france n'échappe pas à cela
comme médecine comme comme staps en fait
on a déjà une une pression qui est forte
au niveau des académies francilienne oui
il ya eu énormément ma ya eu plus de
bacheliers
déjà cette année considérablement
puisqu'il ya un taureau un taux record
de bacheliers je crois que c'est plus de
95% et donc cela implique ya peut-être
des filières où effectivement les
promotions sont plus importantes à noter
cependant que et ça c'est plusieurs
présidents de l'université qu'ils nous
le disent qu'en fait les contaminations
sont surtout observés dans les
formations il ya des petits effectifs ou
la distanciation est plus difficile à
mettre en place parce que ce souci ce
sont souvent des élèves qui se
retrouvent pour travailler qui ont une
dynamique de groupe très importante par
exemple des petites formations
d'ingénieurs de bts ce sont des
étudiants qui se retrouvent beaucoup
après les cours pour pour pour
travailler est en fait la compter les
contaminations selon les présidents des
universités se font surtout dans ces
formations à petits effectifs et
beaucoup moins dans l'est dans les
amphis est en fait surtout si il y à des
contaminations et ça c'est ce que la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
répète depuis plusieurs jours et s'est
également repris par les universités les
contaminations sont ne se font pas par
promotion mais par groupe d'amis donc ce
sont en fait concrètement des étudiants
qui se retrouvent pour faire des fêtes
pour se rassembler et qui ensuite se
contaminent et ramène la cantine
contamination au sein de l'université
oui justement ça nous permet de faire un
lien avec l'une des annonces
alors ça c'est le préfet de police de
paris didier lallement qui l'a fait
cette confirmation et les soirées
étudiantes sont interdites mais dans les
faits clairs à eschede mais des
mécanismes de contrôle on voit pas les
forces de l'ordre arriver chez les gens
comme ça peut être le cas au québec par
exemple
non c'est évidemment c'est c'est très
difficile de contrôler ce que font les
étudiants en dehors d'un établissement
les établissements on m'interdit tous
les fêtes étudiantes dans le cadre donc
d'une promotion et sur place mais
évidemment les étudiants se retrouvent
c'est le début de l'année donc ils
veulent aussi faire connaissance c'est
des choses qui sont extrêmement
difficiles à surveiller et toutes les
semaines il ya des nouveaux chiffres qui
tombent de promo de promo renvoyées chez
elles de centaines d'étudiants a sommé
de rester à la maison parce qu'à la
suite d'une fête d'intégration eh bah il
ya eu une contamination et simon les
renvoie pas chez eux
bahia il ya ce risque donc la
continuation se poursuivent au sein de
la promo une dernière question claire
comme avec tristan 1 pour élargir pour
quitter la seule île de france et est
encore plus sa petite couronne dans les
étudiants que vous interroger au fil de
vos enquêtes de vos reportages pour le
figaro étudiant est ce que il n'y a pas
déjà
finalement une forme de deux
de crainte une forme d'anxiété par
rapport à cette année qui est fait de
deux cours à distance fille de
de réouverture de sites est ce qu'ils
les comprennent quelque chose est ce que
le moral est bon du côté des étudiants
là encore ça dépend il y à des étudiants
on reçoit beaucoup de messages de
d'étudiants de promo qui n'ont toujours
pas eu un seul cours en présentiel ou
alors dans la rentrée a été décalé et
forcément pour eux c'est super difficile
à la rentrée de septembre ni à la
dynamique scolaire de la rentrée de
septembre et sont un peu perdus attendre
que les universités mettent en place une
formation qui soit adaptée à la crise
sanitaire mais d'un autre côté il y en a
qui ont cours le bel et bien cours et
qui désespère un peu des conditions dans
lesquelles ils sont ils sont reçus qui
sont inquiet il y en a qui vit avec des
parents qui sont pas en très bonne santé
il y en a qui vivent avec leurs grands
parents ils ont moins peur pour eux que
du ils ont plutôt peur de transmettre le
virus à leurs proches
et tout cela ça rend leur leurs
conditions d'études très très étrange
il ya aussi les professeurs les
professeurs c'est bizarre aussi parce
qu'il faut veiller à errer un maximum il
faut gérer un flux d'élèves qui parfois
est supérieur aux flux annoncé l'hiver
approche comment on va faire pour ouvrir
les fenêtres
comment on va faire pour ouvrir les
portes sans mourir de froid quoi donc
tout ça c'est des questions qui mettent
énormément de l'injecter énormément
d'angoissé de stress dans cette rentrée
et malheureusement ce ses angoisses
risque de de continuer à se multiplier
je rappelle que tous les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur un classé en
zone d' alerte renforcée ou en zone d'
alerte maximale vont réduire
réduisant déjà c'est déjà le cas de
moitié le nombre d'étudiants accueillis
en présentiel
au même moment et vous nous le disiez un
clair comme la conf ont confirmé les
autorités ça s'applique aussi au passage
dans les restaurants universitaires ou
dans les bibliothèques merci beaucoup
claire conduite d'avoir été avec nos
journaliste au figaro étudiant et merci
triste envie d'être passé sur le plateau
de figaro live le chef adjoint du
service santé médecine du figaro merci à
toutes celles et ceux qui nous ont
suivis sur twitter com vient
certainement de napolitain ou encore
pinho fou de phoenix vpd le cas bonjour
à la homepage évidemment avec philippe
nathan ou encore marco et puis beaucoup
aussi sur youtube à nice ou encore jim
vous pouvez retrouver tous les derniers
développements toutes les dernières
infos sur lefigaro.fr pourrez suivre
notamment les modalités du protocole
sanitaire renforcée dans la restauration
dans les restaurants qui doit être
dévoilé ce protocole dans la journée
très bon début de semaine à toutes et à
tous et bon appétit si vous êtes à table